this is charles
a san esteban island chakwala
part of the iguana family chokwalas are
the largest of the five species
they are endangered due to hunting and
feral animals preying on their eggs
charles is native to san esteban island
a small island in the gulf of california
mexico
it is only in this region where the san
esteban chuck wallace can be found
their coloration provides critical
camouflage from predators
they don't drink water instead getting
all the water they need from the plants
they eat
san esteban chuck wallace can reach over
two and a half feet in size
they are very well adapted for desert
life and enjoy basking in the sun in
temperatures consistently in the low
hundreds
this is the san esteban
[Music]
chakwala this is a male tree pangolin he
is six months old
critically endangered and
under-researched the tree pangolin is a
mammalian species like no other
found throughout asia and africa
pangolins can be traced back 66 million
years meaning they lived amongst
dinosaurs
they're the only mammals on earth
covered in scales which account for
about 20 of their body weight
these large protective scales are made
of keratin
the same thing human nails and hair are
made from
tree pangolins use their long claws to
climb on trees and branches in an
endless search for prey
baby penguins like the one here get
around by riding their mother's tails
though they have poor eyesight and
hearing their strong sense of smell and
elastic tongue allows them to catch a
meal of mostly ants and termites
when the pangolin senses danger it will
curl up into a ball making it almost
invincible in the wild
humans however are a dangerous threat
the pangolin scales are thought to have
healing properties though there's no
science to back that up
because of that pangolins are the most
heavily trafficked mammals in the world
worth almost 300 per pound on the black
market
no one knows how many pangolins are left
but we do know that their number is
shrinking fast
this is the tree penguin
[Music]
this is the colored lizard
the two black bands around their neck
give them their name
colored lizards can actually run on
their hind legs and reach up to 15 miles
per hour
their tails are used for balancing
themselves when they are up and
sprinting
they are a medium-sized lizard reaching
up to a foot and a half in length
native to western north america they
prefer to live in rocky habitats with
sparse vegetation
today they are widespread but only a few
decades ago their population was
declining clearing land as a form of
fire prevention has greatly helped its
population rebound
as they need open rocky habitats to
survive
this is the colored lizard
[Music]
this is the gothica skink
small in size the gothica skink is
covered in camouflage skin to blend in
with the alpine rocks they call home
the gothicus gink is native to victoria
australia and can only be found in one
area known as the bogong high plains
because they are only found in such a
small area they are vulnerable to
natural disasters such as bushfires
but this isn't the only threat facing
the skinks
their habitat has also been affected by
the construction of ski resorts and the
grazing and trampling from farm animals
but their biggest threat is climate
change warmer temperatures have allowed
new predators once kept at bay by the
cold into their previously isolated
habitat
zoos victoria have been working on a
breeding program to ensure the
preservation of this species and a
rescue and recovery program if there is
an immediate threat to the wild
population
[Music]
this is the gothic skink
[Music]
meet onyx a five-year-old eastern indigo
snake
[Music]
at nine feet in length eastern indigos
are considered to be the longest native
snakes in the united states
even though they lack a venomous bite
they can fall victim to overzealous
rattlesnake hunters as they inhabit the
same burrows
their beautiful smooth scaled skin is a
shade of bluish black
carnivorous like all snakes onyx feeds
on any small animal she can overpower
onyx may hiss or rattle her tail when
alarmed but she'll hardly ever bite
like most snakes humans are their
biggest threat as continued urbanization
has left them threatened throughout
parts of the united states
this is the eastern indigo snake
[Music]
this is the massasauga rattlesnake
it is ontario's only venomous snake but
it's more scared of humans than we are
of it
massasaugas aren't very large
growing up to three feet in length
their skin is grey to dark brown dappled
with darker splotches along its back
their tails rattle as a warning yet they
won't strike unless they have no choice
that's because massasaugas are shy and
prefer to hide than bite their enemies
unfortunately they can't hide from
encroaching human development which
combined with intentional killings from
over-exaggerated fear have caused a
large decline in its canadian population
this is the massasauga rattlesnake
[Music]
this is a baby cuban crocodile one of
the rarest crocs in the world
hidden away in only two parts of cuba
they have the smallest range of any croc
species
the cuban crocodile is critically
endangered experts say approximately 3
000 remain in the wild
its bright pebbled scales set it apart
from other crocodiles
they favor freshwater lakes and swamps
rarely venturing into the ocean
their strong swimmers using their
powerful tails to thrust out of the
water catching prey hiding in
overhanging branches
habitat degradation hunting and
interbreeding with related crocodile
species all pose threats
this is the cuban crocodile
you